the horrific beating of Tyree Nichols
sparking a big debate over police reform
the whole nation shocked by the
disturbing body cam footage showing
officers repeatedly pummeling Nichols
who died of those injuries just Days
Later a sixth Memphis police officer
involved in the initial traffic stop has
been suspended that's in addition to the
5x officers who face murder charges
Democrats demanding action but already
dismissing bipartisan efforts at solving
the problem
the police reform package that Senator
Booker was working on with Senator Scott
it had many elements in it that are
important Banning choke holds dealing
with no warrant searches dealing with
accreditation of police departments it's
necessary that we do all these things
but not sufficient and conservatives say
any effort put forward can't rely on
defunding the police
we must stop vilifying the police
we must stop listening to the voices of
Despair angry and division but none of
the leaders who are who are advocating
defundities live in in situations where
there is high crime but the media egging
Democrats on to cut funding to police
departments
this whole reform nonsense from
Democrats is so tiring and so dishonest
you can't reform this stuff with body
cameras or diversifying the police as we
just saw in Memphis that doesn't solve
the problem either
now Democrats of course want to run away
from Talk of abolishing the police or
even defunding the police that's way too
radical way too out there
you don't think the Democrats are
actually going to defund the police no
he's entitled to his opinion but he's
dead wrong look I think a couple of
things I think that um In fairness to
the Senator Senator Durbin uh I do think
what Senator Scott Senator book we're
working on is a foundation I think what
we've seen here in perhaps what some are
asking for is an approach like you have
with our military you know some people
are qualified and are able to serve in
combat or in Special Forces any
specialized units I think are to the
equivalent nothing is like special
forces in the military but as you think
about our police forces and how we
employ and how we hire people and how we
determine who should be in different
units we do this as we defend our
country we should do this for these
Noble and heroic and courageous servants
who are getting a bad rap number two we
need some training and protocol
standards across the country I've seen
some on our Network say that that's akin
to federalizing our police forces but I
don't think so I think there's a way to
strike that balance in this sense it's
here we'll find more about the Scorpion
uh uh unit here I know they've they have
deactivated it in Memphis but you need
these units and police forces all across
the country to go after some of the most
violent and some of the most awful
things that are happening in communities
and oftentimes their communities where
this young fell I won't I don't know the
young fellow I think we put up on MSNBC
there I don't think he lives in those
communities uh God bless him he lives
wherever he wants to live but I think
before we go talking about defunding
something
you need to you need to understand that
police are essential to a functioning
Society what was your reaction to
watching the video
speechless stunned angry I when I looked
at it I said these people are evil they
are full of hate and violence this man
did nothing we still don't know why they
stopped him there is no evidence the
police chief has said that she's aware
of why they stopped him of this alleged
reckless driving we still don't know why
they pulled him out of the car
immediately I mean normally you stop
someone you ask him for a license and
registration we don't know what you know
whether or not someone they knew each
other is there some prior relationship
there why once he was on the ground did
they need to beat him with a baton and
pepper spray him and mace him and tase
him and then sure he ran away I mean I
think he knew ultimately what was going
on because he kept saying I'm doing what
you're telling me to do it is disgusting
and Washington can talk all they want
about police reform and look I work with
cops for 32 years you know it like every
day of my professional life cops that I
know are not like this these people are
evil and there's evil in every group of
bunch of society but the bill that
Booker and Tim Scott were working on the
sticking point was qualified immunity so
should a police officer lose his house
because someone sues him and the issue
of whether or not uh that they're going
to defund police departments if they
don't meet all the standards of reforms
so understand that local police
departments which of the essence of law
enforcement in this country they get
grants from Washington just like I did
and if they're going to say hey you
didn't meet Janine you didn't meet this
criteria therefore we're not giving you
money you're basically defunding me
again the government did funds so you
know and by the way one more thing more
police are going to be charged two more
sheriffs two more firemen in Memphis two
more firemen why were they standing
around for 20 minutes before they did a
darn thing this isn't over yet this is
horrible this isn't who cops are Greg
Garfield yeah I you know when I look at
this I think boy this seems like it was
worse than George Floyd except the
response to it was muted which is what
people think is good now that we we
don't have arson we don't have uh
looting we don't have sustained riots
over weeks where dozens die
uh yet this was worse so what does that
tell you about all of these things in
the past that the media Amplified them
based on race because this is an example
where a variable is controlled and that
is race both sides are black so in this
incident if you remove that variable
what does the media do well they realize
they can't amplify this as a race thing
so it becomes a training thing right
well what does this say about the past
what if all of those other ones were
about training and the only thing that
threw you off that was because there was
a white cop or two white cops and the
media made it about race when in fact it
could have been about training all along
something that we were saying on this
show the entire time we were talking
about training but it was always about
race systematic racism even people today
are saying that it's systematic it's
still white people because it's white
people who did the training as if blacks
don't have the agency to do the right
thing
you know it is it's it's it I I my
favorite my favorite line and I won't
say who said this because it's just so
pathetic
you know uh uh could you imagine those
guys doing that to a white guy
what does that say that says that you're
saying that uh those black men would be
more likely to kill a black man than a
white man what is that what does that
even mean and I'm sorry you can find
tapes of cops doing this to white people
you just don't see an amplified right
and you didn't see this one Amplified
either any nothing like the other ones
and that was because race was removed
and now it's about training we're all
for training we're definitely all for
training training isn't about defunding
the police though and we're gonna have
to start asking ourselves like what
happens when we decide to do die in the
police force speed that up what happens
then when you start changing
requirements lowering requirements you
might have more of that are you willing
to accept that knowing there will be
less riots than if it were white cops
that's something you got to think about
because there will be more there will be
more actions if the training isn't up to
speed if they're not paid as well if the
qualified people are leaving the police
force and replace with people who are
inexperienced you're gonna have that
yeah and and then you're going to say
well at least the after effect is it
right it's because it's black on black
but do you think that maybe there wasn't
the ride sort of whatever because the
the officers were fired and charged I
mean and I think there's a there's some
differences here
but there was some yeah there were some
things here but I would say that's I
would say that you know if there was if
if there was just two white guys in
there it would have been a different
story and I and I and I'm not saying
that it would end it would just be
portrayed differently in the media
one of the things that you bring up is
the retirement and the retention issue
and the recruitment issue yeah so
there's a big problem on all that that
we've been seeing that in major cities
and small towns Across America over the
last several years so what what is the
answer to that well the only antidote to
that is
more money so it's the apps actually the
opposite of uh defund the police because
if you want more money for different
training or if you want to figure out a
way to keep those older officers there
so that there might have been you know
somebody who had several years of
experience on the force rather than all
the young guys all together at once
maybe this could have been avoided I do
think that we will see some more arrests
and perhaps some additional calls for
needs in that Community because one of
the reasons that the Scorpion group was
created and Harold could speak to us
better than I can is is the level of
violence in Memphis got to the point
where the community was saying we need
more protection so they tried and that
was the wrong protection I don't
necessarily think that that means you
have to have Federal legislation perhaps
the federal legislation could be very
good I don't know if it's a Panacea to
actually stop this type of thing right
yeah no it's it's not going to impact
this and you know what it's a training
protocol within the local police
department and by the way Minneapolis
can also charge these guys because these
cops have a duty to intervene if deadly
forces unjustified is being used against
an individual and by the way this
department is down 500 cups right think
about that's why I think that's why
there's going to be a call for more
money and to fund them because you're
going to have to have that and I'd just
like to say um you know you covered the
news live on prime time on Friday night
and I thought you did an incredible job
Jess you really really top-notch work so
much you were like the anti-eagles that
night I was yeah and then I went back to
being hated I want to Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now